all right Richard Richard wait former
John where'd you grow up I grew up New
York New York and hey and how was your
childhood you grew up with both your
parents I grew up with my mother both of
my parents were in the service
I was in military school and that's it
we took it from there they separated
when I was three it was all disturbing
but yeah yeah you think they have to
give us sometimes yep brothers and
sisters I have one sister and how was
your childhood how was your childhood
can't cry you physically sexually it was
a lot of different changes I mean if you
want to but get somewhere in life
sometimes you had to do I mean I was a
that was an escort
sometime I would age thank you
thirteen yeah and who's watched your mom
no no my mom that are worth just keep us
a look and I try to not be a burden to
her what I did was I try to do the best
in school as I could but then who at
thirteen who's kind of school is maybe
five blocks away I walk there and I was
an altar boy yeah
so the 18 year old he passes you know
with Cardinal cook okay and there was
the different experience I was an altar
boy I used to officer get me in trouble
ah I thought at ease all I wanted to do
is make something out of my alright just
like my dad my dad was an electrician
years in the Navy and yeah I said it
from there you know he put my mother
pushed me as much as she could and I did
the most I could ya help out so you
brought home money again
and how long did this go on alright oh
really yeah it's so mom passed away so I
had moved out got married had my
daughter my daughters uh 21 she's in
college straight-a student great that's
so cool I was saying hard for most of my
life yeah what they're doing out here
and how are they doing
it's all work out there
demolitions expert so that's what I did
it was a different experience I'm go
ahead somebody took the other the other
way and I learned quite that there was
uh a real real experience I mean all in
job training
well you can't get that anywhere get to
blow stuff up mess that's well it's not
so much just that has been safe it's you
know doing the life fuses and stuff like
that we doing explosions - you know
leaving the pile right there dropping an
excavator down so I'll buck it up and
stand it back up himself
oh cool so that was your career for a
lot of your like foot play sometime
Robbie tenant Robbie is but but you see
the escorting thing was kind of going on
for that went on I was about 20 and it
was that wasn't it yeah it was weird I
couldn't get used to strangers I I did
the most I could to make the most of
that good
yeah how about how did your parents
wonder where the money was coming from
yeah oh would you tell them I lied
there's some things are just better left
unsaid for me then you were doing it for
your own gain you were just helping your
family I was and then I started yeah
it's a good apartment with this
nice lady yeah the Sheffield's Amazon
wasn't seven and that's where she went
her or business and she did quite well
so what I do is out pretty much the
smaller piece all right
anything that to you and our piece for
the rich ladies on the Upper East Side
bargain yeah but your art piece for the
rich ladies in the Upper East Side I was
and they
yeah you make them feel important you
put them on you know at the top and
treat them for somebody cooler and a lot
of respect and they liked it yeah they
like to feel important a larger woman
can be treated yeah yeah how the hell
did this go on
as I said explain till you're 20 and it
have you have you done anything similar
to that after 20 no so there's I'm gonna
need offers there not much this morning
there any bother
yeah it's so today you're living on Skid
Row okay I'm living in a second
apartment
oh yeah see ya housing I just know what
you got housing I did it only took two
years
are you using any of the drugs on the
street I did at one point again which
was huh
we struck oh yeah yeah and you got off
good yeah yeah how'd you get off it I
always tired of it I'm getting older 57
and I had a lot more important things in
my life going on make my wife my
daughter go in college and immediately
so so you important so you're off drugs
now
yeah how difficult was it you get clean
of heroin it was your determination your
commitment that's all you have to want
to get retired
you have to retire
looking back in your life what what do
you wish it happened differently or what
regrets do you have I wish my other
father steak you gave it which was out
in front for me cuz that was well I
actually got my strength in my power
from I mean he pushed me to where I
needed to be yes and I trusted them
this is not the easiest thing in the
world to do you just don't trust
everybody
and then when they thought passed on I
mean jeez I just thought of growing up
at 38 years old my mother penny
sheltered me from this jungle and that's
totally a bad for it didn't know what to
expect where I was going to see what I
was gonna experience mmm I felt good I'm
raising a daughter so and being a minor
and when did you come to Los Angeles
when I came in Los Angeles because I
wanted to do some finish work at what
age I was he now 54
oh it is recently yeah and Skid Row is
perhaps the worst part of Los Angeles
it sure was but I'll tell you what it
opened my eyes to a lot of things gave
me some decision and gave me some
direction on where I wanted to go I knew
I hit and where I was like that I knew
my mother a lot of effort into teaching
me or showing me
adilyn and what was important in life
sure and
he always asked me for my advice and how
I thought about what she was asking me I
tell ya it's very important to have a
mentor guys if you don't I'd take you
hours I did a couple years in prison and
you see these young kids they locked up
with your father
I need to know how did he do that I saw
in New Jersey where I think I start the
transition breathing ass make a halfway
house so to speak from my HP and they
had to come into the house pay right go
to work make your meeting so forth until
then I was there
Delsin and point them in the right
direction and it was successful eat out
here it needs a lot more attention and
it would be it would take a lot of your
time birthday when it's all said and
done you'll get at least a few good guys
that really want to change your eyes and
do something with it you know it's all I
heard out of them one I want to do
something different my right now oh my
god they're banging I wanted so good I
don't want to do this I don't want to do
that you know I want you something
different that's gonna mean something my
way that was good and spicy
so they need a little push and that's
something you can just agree that of a
book you honey get or living see half of
it because they won't accept it from
anybody else they're sick
but you'll know it's not real or you're
not telling them the truth
you know it has to be accepting and then
and they won't want to change and do
something different
me myself but that's something I want to
do something different so I was shining
said you know that's all I want to be
useful I don't love your ways and of God
didn't put me on the shard to Mia
Oh waste yeah I mean you walk around you
see some of the people I mean it's like
Jesus what are you doing okay
it's is it and you have to create your
own ideas and what you want to put up or
put forth that's okay yeah
so my guy said being a mentor for some
some people or you're a gentleman
it's definitely I'm not gonna it's a
positive way to go you're there you're
showing them the way to go you ready and
doing as you should do and onions it
guys this is what life is all about you
can go out down your work you make a
paycheck putting on Taylor give to your
wife take care of your kids yeah and
originally kids for yourself I'm Hallie
had one and I did it myself
you did it yourself without what I did
where was our work Annie I really do min
hand there was your watch huh where was
the mother the mother was down in Jersey
why did she leave uh usually cocaine
drug she couldn't stop she worked
yourself Omar police as a dispatcher and
stuff and I just know if you think that
took place didn't happen and I couldn't
allow that to happen to my daughter
I didn't want her to fall into a bunch
of our world
yeah I wanted to be sure yet every
opportunity yeah
and that was important we don't wanna
get from me that's cool
thanks Richard thank you so much for
talking to me absolutely and good luck
with everything
very interesting
you